as the president has discovered being a
disruptor has its personal downsides
whether it's the border wall or troop
withdrawals from Syria and Afghanistan
the swamp is committed to holding him
back the antagonism he continues to face
from his political opponents is vicious
but as we saw last night when they are
calmly confronted with clarity
they're often flummoxed Trump has
co-opted some of their big issues like
fair trade criminal justice reform in
opposition to endless military
intervention ISM now last night Trump
though tried to find some common cause
we must reject the politics of revenge
resistance and retribution and embrace
the boundless potential of cooperation
compromise and the common good we can
bridge all divisions heal old wounds
build new coalition's forge new
solutions and unlock the extraordinary
promise of America's future Nancy Pelosi
smirk notwithstanding last night the
president did something few expected he
attempted to unify the country he was
even magnanimous toward his most hostile
critics giving the ghost gals the throng
of white suited lefties they're due
don't sit yet you know like this we also
have more women serving in Congress than
any
[Applause]
the president accomplished something
there that his enemies may have missed
there now while they were clearly
chanting USA as a celebration of
themselves Trump got them to take up the
refrain usually reserved for you know
his rallies now for a moment even the
Democrats experienced what so many
Americans around the country have
experienced at a trump rally a sense of
vibrant community a patriotic chanting
together
not something nasty but something
positive our country but the good
feelings didn't last too long
NPR repaid the president's magnanimity
with a phony fact check where they
insisted that the number of women in
Congress was quote almost entirely
because of Democrats not Trump's party
speaker Pelosi attempted to make the
same insipid point she was a 15
Republicans in 91
Democratic women in the Congress of the
United States it was it was like weird
you're bringing this up now this is a
woman who looked like she was reading a
menu at a Chinese restaurant during the
speech and she's saying that was weird
the president never said we have more
Republican women serving in Congress
than any time before he only saluted the
fact that there were more women serving
because some people can't even take a
compliment but it doesn't matter I think
because the American people saw the
president trying to reach out they also
saw a side of him that often gets lost
the caring grandfatherly and yes even
tender side of Donald Trump joining
Melania in the gallery this evening is a
very brave ten year old girl Gracie line
every birthday
he saluted our World War 2 veterans
Holocaust survivors and Buzz Aldrin it
was a thoroughly American evening where
people felt good about the country and I
think just the average person not the
jaded people in Washington LA and New
York but the regular folks they just
reveled in seeing our heroes from
decades ago and even some new ones once
or twice the president even managed to
get both sides of the aisle to rise in
support of a legislative agenda and an
item that some people laughed at a year
ago including Paul Ryan paid family
leave look at Chuck Schumer even jumping
to his feet I'm also proud to be the
first president to include on my budget
a plan for nationwide paid family leave
now what it was over I think the left
was kind of grasping for something
anything please help them give him
something to criticize that the
president itíd States at this moment in
the world did not mention climate change
in even a sentence is just frankly a
disgrace there were soldiers who were
transgender who have been thrown out of
the military
he didn't mention them this is the same
speech Donald Trump always gives this is
an angry and racist platform that has
been surrounded by sweet stories and
World War two veterans oh my god I mean
they sounded so ridiculous like sex
trafficking and criminal justice reform
and we're gonna get into this but that
is just dishonest it's ridiculous for
them to say that what the State of the
Union did was remind the American people
of how much good the president has done
over the last two years not perfect but
he's not a lot of good things not only
economically either it's not what I'm
talking about
also on foreign policy which he's
derided for by the smart set over at
MSNBC and also for the cause of life the
most vulnerable among us the speech
vividly revealed the contrast between
his vibrant policies that are very clear
and the
Hale colorless agenda of the left now
there now the party of what think about
the left the Democrats infanticide open
borders drug legalization racializing
politics
everybody's a racist right banning cars
the green agenda and for some socialism
what's your view of your party's drift
not entirely but in many prominent
members toward socialism I wouldn't
quite call it socialism there are with
others who want to live around except
its sector but yeah but the bottom line
is that all of us believe that when you
look at the State of the Union on the
economy it's not good for middle-class
families and so you know Masson what's
really happening here and the president
is just not doing that it's a softer
version of socialism Schumer style well
the President may not have United
Congress last night but he even if I'd
many I think out there watching the
American people by kind of pulling off
the masks of some of these naysayers the
negativity purveyors a Democratic Party
today during that speech and it was it
was kind of long people were saying it
was too long but I got a text from
people saying they wanted it to go on
longer they loved the stories and they
loved the hope in that speech and I
think many saw perhaps for the first
time the reality of what the Left
represents and how opposed they are to
the common sense good policies that
Trump has brought to Washington the
petulance and the nastiness that
Democrats displayed last night I think
is going to be remembered well into 2020
so will Donald Trump's confident
kindness but don't worry the Dems were
hard at work trying to repair their
reputations today as the chair of the
House Judiciary Committee Jerry Nadler
chalked up a big win for his party he
eliminated the so help me God
line from the hearings swearing-in until
well a Republican colleague insisted
that he put it back in
heck of a job Jerry you go knock
yourself out he was trying to eat away
at the fabric of America I think most of
the country would rather celebrate our
traditions as Donald Trump did last
night and that's the angle